PROFESSOR: All right, I would
like to then get back to a
discussion of some of the basic
relations that we have
been discussing.
We didn't get terribly far, but
I'd like to start with the
Cartesian coordinate system
that we set up.
Rather than using x, y, and
z, I'm labeling the
axes x1, x2, and x3.
And we'll see that the
subscripts play a very useful
role in the formalism we're
about to develop.
Now, the first thing we might
want to specify in this
coordinate is the orientation
of a vector and its
components.
So let's suppose that this is
some vector P. And what I will
do to define its orientation
is to use the three angles
that the vector makes, or the
direction makes with respect
to x1, x2, x3.
And we could define these angles
as theta1, that's the
angle between the direction
and x1, theta2, the angle
between our direction or our
vector and x2, and finally,
not surprisingly, I'll
call this one theta3.
So the three components of the
vector could be written as P1,
the component along x1 is going
to be the magnitude of P
times the cosine of theta1.
The x2 component of P would be
the magnitude of P times the
cosine of theta2.
And P3, the third component,
would be the magnitude of P
times the cosine of theta3.
Now, we will have so many
relations that involve the
cosine of the angle between
a direction and one of our
reference axes that it is
convenient to define a special
term for the cosines
of these angles.
So I'll define this as magnitude
of P times the
quantity l1, magnitude of P
times l2, magnitude of P times
l3, which is a lot
easier to write.
And we will define
these things as
the direction cosines.
With these equations it's easy
to attach some meaning to the
direction cosines.
Suppose we had a vector of
magnitude 1, something that we
will refer to as
a unit vector.
And if we put in magnitude of P
equal to 1, it follows that
l1m l2m l3 are simply the
components of a unit vector in
a particular direction along,
obviously, x1, x2, and x3,
respectively.
Trivial piece of algebra, but
it attaches a physical and
geometric significance to
the direction cosines.
Now, the vector is something
that could represent a
physical quantity.
In any case, it is something
that is absolute.
And it sits embedded
majestically, relative to some
absolute coordinate system.
The magnitudes of the components
P1, P2, and P3 will
change their values if we would
decide to change the
coordinate system that we're
using as our reference system.
So the next question we might
ask is, suppose we change the
coordinate system to some new
values, x1 prime, x2 prime,
and x3 prime?
And I'll illustrate my point
with just a two dimensional
analog of this.
This is x1, and this is x2.
And this is my vector P.
And I change x1 to some new
value, x1 prime, and change x2
to some new orientation,
x2 prime.
Then clearly the component of
P on x1 has changed its
numerical value if I refer
it to x1 prime instead.
And similarly, this value would
be the component P2.
If I change the direction of x2
and draw a perpendicular to
x2, this would be P2 prime.
So if I change coordinate system
along the fashion I
suggested, the three components
of a vector, P1,
P2, P3, are going to change to
some new values, P1 prime, P2
prime, P3 prime.
OK.
So the question I'd like to
address next is given the
change of coordinate system, and
given the three components
of P in the original coordinate
system, how do I
compute the values of the
new components P1 prime,
P2 prime, P3 prime?
I'll say it in words, and then
we'll define a mechanism for
specifying the change in
coordinate system.
What I'll say is-- and this
was apparent in the sketch
that I just erased--
the new component of the vector
P1 prime is simply
going to be the sum of the
components of P1, P2, and P3
along the new x prime
direction.
So I'm saying that this is going
to be the sum of the
component of P1 along x1 plus
the component of P2 along x1
prime and the component
of P3 along x1 prime.
So in short, I'm doing nothing
more complicated than saying,
I can get the values of the new
components if I take the
vector P, split it up into its
three parts, and then find the
component of each of these three
parts along the x1 prime
access, then do the same thing
for the x2 prime axis, and
then the same thing
for x3 prime.
So I'm going to need, now, a
notation for a change in a
three-dimensional Cartesian
coordinate system.
So here is x1, here is
x2, and here is x3.
And I will change them.
And again, I'm always
keeping the
coordinate system Cartesian.
So here's an x1 prime, here's an
x2 prime, and then x3 prime
will point out in some
direction like this.
I don't want a prime on that.
So I'm going to say now that the
component of P along the
new x1 prime is going to be the
magnitude of P1 times the
cosine of the angle between x1
and x1 prime, plus P2 times
the cosine of the angle
between x1 and--
am I doing this right?
P1 onto x1 prime.
And I want P2 onto x1 prime.
So this is going to be the angle
between x2 and x1 prime
plus P3 times the cosine
of the angle
between x3 and x1 prime.
Well, we used C's or
l earlier on to
represent a direction cosine.
Let me define Cij as the cosine
of the angle between x1
prime, xi prime, and x sub j.
So that means I can write this
expression here in this nice
compact form.
With our definition of direction
cosines, I can say
that P1 prime is going to be
equal to C1 1 times P1 plus C1
2 times P2 plus C1 3 times P3.
Can write that P2 prime
in the same way.
It's going to be the cosine of
the angle between P2 prime and
P1 and x1, plus the cosine of
the angle between x2 prime and
x2 times P2 plus C2 3 which
is the cosine of the angle
between x2 prime and x3,
times the component P3.
And in a very similar fashion,
P3 prime will be C3 1 P1 plus
C3 2 times P2 plus
C3 3 times P3.
So here is the way a vector
will transform.
And we can write this compactly
in matrix form.
We can say that P sub i prime,
where this is a column matrix,
one by three, is going to be
equal to Cij, a three by three
matrix times the original
components of the
vector P sub j.
And just to cement the notation
that we're using, if
I put my old axes up here, x1,
x2, x3, and put the new axes,
x1 prime, x2 prime, x3 prime,
down this way, then the cosine
of the angle between the
quantities that are in this
column and the quantities that
are in this row would be C1 1,
C1 2, C1 3, C2 1, C2 2, C2
3, C3 1, C3 2, C3 3.
Nothing fancy except
the notation.
It's the description of some
very simple geometry.
This array, Cij, is something
that I will refer to as a
direction cosine scheme.
Let me pause here and see if
that's all sunk in, whether
you have any questions
on this.
One of the nasty properties of
what we're going to be doing
for the next month or so is that
the notions are really
very, very simple, but the
notation is horribly
cumbersome and complex.
So it takes a bit of getting
used to in application to
actual real cases before you
feel fully at home with it.
OK.
Just a matter of definition
so far.
Let me note that this direction
cosine array is
going to be useful for defining
how a vector changes
as we go from the original
coordinate system to a new
coordinate system.
But this direction cosine array
will also tell us how
the axes in one coordinate
system are related to the axes
in the new coordinate system.
It follows from the fact that
the axes themselves can be
regarded as unit vectors.
And we said that the components
of a unit vector
are the direction cosines of
that vector, relative to a
coordinate system.
So let's ask, what are the new
components of x1 in terms of
the original axes unprimed.
Well, x1 prime is going to be
the unit vector x1 times the
cosine of the angle between x1
and x1 prime, plus the unit
vector along x2 prime times
the cosine of the angle
between x1 prime, and x2.
And that's C1 2.
Plus x3 regarded as a unit
vector times the cosine of the
angle between x1 prime and x3.
So we can actually write an
equation for unit vectors
along each of our new axes.
And they will go as C1 1 times
x1, C1 2 times x2, C1 3 times
x3, plus C2 2 times x2 plus C2
3 times x3 times x3 prime.
And x3 primal will be C3 1 x1
plus C3 2 x2 plus C3 3 x3.
So this, then, is an equation
between the unit vectors along
the three reference axes in
the new coordinate system
relative to those in the
original coordinate system.
And the direction cosine
scheme does the job.
OK.
We could, using the same
argument, give the array that
specifies the reverse
transformation.
If we would change our mind, for
example, and say we don't
like what we've done, let's
write the original coordinate
system x1, x2, and x3 in terms
of the unit vectors
along the new axes.
And we can use exactly
the same array.
We can say that the original x1,
in terms of the three new
axes, x1 prime, x2 prime, and x3
prime, is going to involve
the cosine of the angle between
x1 prime and x1, and
that is C1 1, plus the cosine of
the angle between x2 prime
and x1, and that's C2 1, plus
the cosine of the angle
between x3 prime and
x1, and that C3 1.
If we continue on this, if you
have the idea, the angle x2 is
going to be given in terms of
x1 prime, x2 prime, and x3
prime, as the cosine of the
angle between x2 and x1 prime,
and that is C1 2.
Here we want the cosine of the
angle between x2 and x2 prime,
and here the cosine of the angle
between x3 prime and x2.
And you can see the way
this is playing out.
C1 3 times x1 plus C2
3, x2 prime plus
C3 3 times x3 prime.
So there's the reverse
transformation, using the same
array of coefficients as
we did the first time.
So it turns out if we write this
symbolically in a compact
form, xi prime is given
by Cijx sub j.
And the reverse transformation
using the same direction
cosine says that xi is going to
be Cji times x sub j prime.
In other words, the reverse
transformation, let's write it
as Cij minus 1, the inverse
transformation, turns out to
be simply Cji.
And that, in matrix algebra, is
written as the transpose of
the original array
of coefficients.
And transpose is either given by
a squiggle, a tilde on top
of the matrix.
Some people like to use a
superscript T. But we'll use
this particular notation.
But you can see either
notation used to
indicate the transpose.
The array Cij, which has this
property, and it also has
another property which I won't
bother to prove, but the
determinant of Cij
is equal to 1.
And this is something called
a unitary matrix.
Unitary matrix has the property
that the inverse
matrix is the transpose.
We will very, very shortly start
writing down numbers for
some specific transformations.
And then I think that will give
us a little facility in
doing these manipulations.
Comments or questions?
Is this old stuff or old stuff
for which the notation is
still confusing?
All right.
Let me point out something
that is
perhaps apparent to you.
And that is that not all nine
of these numbers are
independent.
There are relations
between them.
And let's point out some
of these relations.
C1 1, C1 2, C1 2 represent the
components of a unit vector
along x1 prime, in the original
coordinate system of
the elements in any
row is equal to 1.
Because these are the components
of a unit vector.
And the magnitude of
a unit vector is 1.
In the same way, if we look at
any column of terms in this
matrix, for example, C1 1, C2 1,
C3 1, these are terms that
represent the cosine of angles
between x1 in the original
coordinate system and x1 prime,
x2 prime, x3 prime, our
new coordinate system.
So this gives us the magnitude
of x1, but
x1 is a unit vector.
So it follows that the sum of
the column C1 1 squared plus
C2 1 squared plus C3 1 squared
also has to be unity, because
that gives us the magnitude of a
unit vector along x1, So the
sum of the squares of elements
in any column of the direction
cosine is unity.
These expressions are useful.
But they have one ambiguity.
That is the cosine of an angle
can be either positive or
negative, depending on whether
the angle is less than 90
degrees or greater
than 90 degrees.
These relations involve the
squares of direction cosines,
and therefore we can't tell
whether the direction cosine
itself is positive
or negative.
So let me put down a
limitation here.
And that is we cannot
tell the sign.
Every time I point this out
to people I wince inside.
Because I once spent two weeks
trying to debug a computer
program, and it wasn't
working.
And it turns out the reason it
wasn't working properly was
that I didn't realize that you
cannot tell the sign when all
you know is the squares of
the direction cosines.
So I remember this as a rather
pointed observation.
Happily, there are other
relations among this array of
coefficients.
This row of terms represents the
components of x1 prime in
the original coordinate
system x1, x2, x3.
This row immediately below it
represents the components of a
unit vector x2 prime relative
to the original coordinate
system x1, x2, x3.
Our coordinate systems
are Cartesian.
Therefore, this unit vector has
to be perpendicular to the
unit vector along x2 prime.
And that means their dot
product has to be 0.
So let me indicate
that this way.
The unit vector along x1 prime
dotted with the unit vector
along x2 prime has to be 0.
And that dot product is going to
be C1 1 times C2 1, that's
the product of these two terms,
plus C1 2 times C2 2
plus C1 3 times C2 3.
And that has to be 0.
And this involves only
the first product of
the direction cosine.
So to make it come out 0 when
we add up the magnitudes, we
will get the sign of the
direction cosine.
So this is a much more
powerful relation.
And similarly, the product of
the coefficients in the first
and the third row have
to add up to 0.
And the second and third
row have to be 0.
So there are three different
relations we can write between
products of corresponding
coefficients in the rows.
So to sum up in words,
the sum of the
corresponding elements--
of the product of--
in any pair of rows
of Cij must be 0.
But we're not done yet.
If we look at the columns in
this array, this represents
the components of x1 relative
to x1 prime,
x2 prime, x3 prime.
And these terms here represent
the components of x2 relative
to x1 prime, x2 prime,
and x3 prime.
And for similar reasons, the
dot product of those two
vectors has to be 0.
So we can say that in addition,
the sum of any sum
of pairs of corresponding
coefficients in any pair of
columns must be 0.
So we're working here on the
direct matrix of the
transformation.
We've seen that the reverse
relation, the inverse matrix
of Cij is Cij transpose.
And therefore the inverse matrix
has to have this same
relationship that the products
of terms and rows or columns,
any pair of rows or columns
has to be 0.
Now, there's one other pair
of relations among the
coefficients, which
is not quite so
geometrically obvious.
And I won't attempt
to prove it.
I'll just state it.
I said a moment ago that these
are unitary matrices.
The determinant of the
coefficient Cij
then has to be unity.
But interestingly, it will be
plus 1 if one goes from a
right-handed system to a
right-handed system.
That is to say the set of
axes x1, x2, x3 might be
right-handed.
And if the new coordinate system
x1 prime, x2 prime, x3
prime is also right-handed,
then the determinant of
coefficients is plus 1.
On the other hand, if one goes
from a right-handed system to
a left-handed reference system
or from a left-handed one to a
right-handed coefficient,
then, interestingly the
determinant of coefficients
is minus 1.
So the determinant of the matrix
of the transformation
is plus 1 if you go
to coordinate
system of the same chirality.
It's equal to minus 1 if you go
to a coordinate system of
changed chirality.
All right, so to repeat
something I said at the outset
but which you now probably truly
believe, the elements in
the direction cosine scheme
that get you from one
coordinate system to another
have lots of inter-relations.
And all of these coefficients
are not independent.
There are these relations
that couple them.
How are we doing on time?
We mentioned last time that a
large collection of physical
properties of materials are
properties that relate a pair
of vectors.
So let me, to make this
specific, talk about a
particular physical property,
electrical conductivity.
And electrical conductivity
relates a current density
vector, and that it charge per
unit area per unit time to an
applied vector, and
that vector is the
electric field vector.
And the electric field has
units of volts per unit
length, so volts per
meter in MKS.
And provided the electric field
that's supplied is not
too strong, it turns out that
every component of the current
flow is given by a linear
combination of every component
of the applied electric field.
So the flow of current along
x1 will be given by a
proportionality constant, an
element sigma 1 1 times the x1
component of the
electric field.
Let me write it out the first
couple of times we do this.
Sigma 1 1 times E1 plus sigma
1 2 times E2 plus
sigma 1 3 times E3.
J2 will be sigma 2 1 times E1
plus sigma 2 2 times E2 plus
sigma 2 3 times E3.
And J3 will be equal to sigma
3 1 times E1 plus sigma 3 2
times E2 plus sigma
3 3 times E3.
Looks formally like the relation
between unit vectors
that define a coordinate
system.
Number of subscripts is the
same, but actually this is
something that's completely
different.
It's dealing with vectors
that have some physical
significance.
So in compact reduced subscript
notation, this is
the definition of electrical
conductivity.
This matrix that relates the
electric field vector to the
current density vector is
said to be a tensor
of the second rank.
OK, tensor.
First thing you might
say, why do you call
it a tensor, dummy?
It's a matrix.
It's a plain old matrix.
There's a subtle but very
important difference.
A tensor is a matrix
with an attitude.
And I'll make the distinction
clear a little bit later on.
But there are tensors
also of higher rank.
These expressions where
summation over repeated
subscripts is implied can hide,
as I indicated last
time, some absolutely horrendous
polynomials.
But tensor at very least is a
term that makes the faces of
all who hear it pale, and makes
the knees of even the
very strong to weaken.
And in case you don't believe
that, I'll show you what I
have to wear whenever I
give these lectures.
And consequently it's kind
of scuzzy and worn out.
But I have to put on
these knee braces
from wobbling braces.
And you can see what
it says on here.
"Tensor." So that's a
consequence of this
frightening definition
that we've just made.
Let me next set the stage for
what we ought to do next.
E sub j represents the
components of an electric
field, x1, x2, x3, in a first
coordinate system.
ji represent the components
of the current flow in a
coordinate system, x1, x2, x3.
If we were to change coordinate
system for any
reason, these three numbers
would wink on and off.
Some might go negative.
The magnitudes would change.
And as a result, the components
of the current flow
would have to do
the same thing.
Because the components of
these vectors, without
changing anything physically,
have to change their numerical
values if we refer them to a
new set of reference axes.
If we change coordinate system
and these numbers change, and
if we change coordinate system,
these numbers change,
we're still applying field
in the same direction.
The current still flows
But the components
we use to define
these two vectors change.
And it follows just
algebraically, the elements of
the tensor have to change and
link into different values.
It follows automatically.
So a question, then, is that
if we have a coordinate
system, x1, x2, x3, and we
change it into a new
coordinate system, x1 prime, x2
prime, x3 prime, then j sub
i changes to some new values,
j sub i prime.
E sub j changes to some new
values, E sub j prime.
And therefore, of necessity,
sigma i j, the conductivity
tensor, has to change to new
values sigma ij prime.
So I'll let you rest up to
brace yourself for this.
The question is, how can we get
sigma ij prime, the nine
elements of the tensor in the
new coordinate system, in
terms of the direction cosine
scheme that defines this
transformation and in terms of
the elements of the original
conductivity tensor?
And this, my friends, is what
makes a tensor a tensor and
not a matrix.
I can write a matrix for you,
a really lovely matrix.
Let's put in some
elements here.
Let's put in 6.2, square root
of minus 1e, and 23.
And as other elements, I'll
put in pi 23.4, 6, and 0.
It's a perfectly good matrix.
It's just an array of numbers,
any numbers, real or
imaginary, or whatever I like.
So this is a matrix.
What a tensor is, is a matrix
for which a law of
transformation is defined.
And that's what makes
a tensor a tensor.
What does it mean to take this
two-by-four matrix that I just
wrote down?
How do I transform that to a
different coordinate system?
It's meaningless, just
an array of numbers.
It's an array of numbers that
has some useful properties,
like matrix multiplication
and the like.
But to talk about transformation
of this set of
four ridiculous numbers to a
new coordinate system is
something that's absolutely
meaningless.
Not so for something like
conductivity or the
piezoelectric moduli or
the elastic constants.
These change their values.
There's a law of transformation
when we go from
one Cartesian reference
system to another.
So what we will do when and if
you return is to derive a law
for transformation for
second-rank tensors, and then,
by implication, look at
higher-rank tensors and decide
how they would transform.
But why would you
want to do this?
Why would you want to muck
things up and have to worry
about transforming
these numbers?
Well, let me give you just
one simple example.
Suppose we had conductivity
of a plate, of a crystal.
And what would you do?
You'd measure it relative to a
set of axes, which, if you
have a little fragment
of crystal, you have
no reference system.
So say that the axes x of i
are taken relative to the
lattice constants of the
material, so relative to the
edges of the unit
cell, possibly.
Then you decide that this
material really has some
useful properties, and you would
like to cut a piece out
of it so that you get a plate
for which the maximum
conductivity in that plate
is in a direction
normal to the plate.
So you know just what sort of
plate you want to cut out.
You know what the direction
cosines are.
But once you've cut a plate from
the crystal, the tensor
relative to the old axes, x1,
x2, x3, is not going to be
terribly useful.
You're going to want to find the
tensor relative to this as
one set of axes, and these
perhaps as a new set of axes
within the plane of the plate.
So there's a good example.
Cut a piece from a crystal and
cut that piece so that the
extreme values are along
x, y, and z for the
new coordinate system.
Then you will be faced with the
necessity of transforming
the tensor from one coordinate
system to another one.
Or you might measure the thermal
conductivity tensor.
You might want to cut a rod out
of the material so that
the maximum conductivity
or the minimum thermal
conductivity is along the
direction of the rod.
You might want to use that as a
push rod to hold a sample in
position and not have it be
a big heat sink for the
temperature that's inside
of your sample chamber.
So I've hopefully convinced
you that there are lots of
cases where it would be
necessary and convenient to
transform the tensor that
describes a property to a new
coordinate system.
All right, so let us
take our break now.
Some internal clock always tells
me when it's five of the
hour, unless I get really
excited about something.
And it is indeed
that time now.
So let's stop.